okay
welcome everyone to bioinformatics for
infectious diseases
in today's session we'll speak about the
emergence
and the development of bioinformatics
and the application
of bioinformatics and infectious disease
research and applications
we'll discuss what infectious disease
are
how they can be categorized from a data
perspective how could they be studied
and specifically we'll focus on next
generation sequencing data so what
methodologies are there that we can
apply to the study of infectious
diseases
we'll also talk a little bit about some
of the tools
and resources associated with the
program that you can leverage
in between sessions and tackle some of
the logistical questions that you might
have
get to know each other so hopefully all
of you here
are ready to study
bioinformatics and learn about
infectious diseases
and so to kind of move on into
the topics of today's session we will go
over
some of the examples of bioinformatics
analysis methods that are used in
pathogen diagnostics spiral evolutionary
studies
antiviral drug discovery vaccine design
and the characterization for emerging
drug resistance
and so we'll talk a little bit about
different tools different data types and
different methods
and that will get us started for today's
program
but before we go on let me tell you a
little bit about
us so pine biotech is a technology
transfer company
that was originally developed at the
university of haifa
so they developed some techniques for
methods
easy to use methods of bioinformatics
analysis
and this was started by dr alfred tauber
who comes from a medical background
and has extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
and has been recognized internationally
for his generous support of many
research projects and initiatives
that support data science training in
applications in
medicine and also dr lena brodsky who is
the director
of the tiger bioinformatics research
center at university of haifa
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
together with our team what we do is
really translate the tools and the
methods that have been developed
at the center and at large for the
application of different
biomedical and other types of studies to
make them more user-friendly and to
train a community of users
how to use them effectively so
what are we going to study in this
program
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
is going to be focused on the different
types of data resources and tools that
you can use to apply
bioinformatics to publicly available
data sets
on infectious diseases and so we'll talk
and understand viral diversity and its
role in epidemic
infectious diseases that keep
re-emerging including zoonotic
transmission
transmission of disease between humans
and the process of viral and bacterial
disease development
we will also learn about
bioinformatics analysis approaches to
study viral genomes
as well as bacterial and other types of
pathogens
and we will talk about different strains
haplotypes how to find differences
in different sequences and how to
associate them with phenotypes
and as a result of completing this
program
you will gain some hands-on experience
hopefully by
analyzing curated data sets that we've
sourced from public domain collections
that were developed into training
tutorials
guided by experts with bioinformatics
experience and
knowledge about different aspects of
infectious disease
so let's talk a little bit about the
difference between
infectious and non-infectious diseases
so
an infection is the invasion of an
organism's body tissues by
disease-causing agents their
multiplication
and the reaction of host tissues to the
infectious agents
and the toxins they produce an
infectious disease
also known as a transmissible disease or
communicable disease
is an illness resulting from that
infection
infections are caused by infectious
agents that we call pathogens and these
can include
viruses and related agents such as
viroids bacteria fungi
parasites and those parasites could be
unicellular organisms like malaria
taxoplasma vibesia
or macro parasites like worms or helmets
so non-infectious diseases are also
recognized as
chronic diseases and can be caused by
such factors as the environment
nutrition and lifestyle as well as
genetic
inheritance the world health
organization recognizes
only four main types of chronic diseases
and non-infectious diseases cancer
cardiovascular chronic respiratory
disease like
asthma or chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease
copd and diabetes
so the replication of pathogens in the
host
leads to major interference that starts
from
membrane disruption of an individual
cell as in the case of viruses
and the release of toxins as in the case
of many bacterial pathogens
many of these interferences induce
molecular biological pathways designed
to fend off intruders and signal to
neighboring cells of danger
the pathogens can also modulate these
pathways and cause
long-term organ damage such as lung
tissue scarring
due to the immune hyperactivity
hosts can fight infections using their
immune system
mammalian hosts react to infections with
an innate response
often involving inflammation followed by
an adaptive response vaccines are used
to train the immune system to identify
pathogens
and store the necessary epitopes for
antibody production in the long term
immune memory
but due to a variety of factors such as
immune response
can be insufficient on their own
two main approaches that have
significantly reduced deaths from
infectious diseases in the past century
are the use of antibiotics antiviral
drugs
and vaccines so
vaccines have been discovered first as
far back as early 1800s
and becoming major instruments to train
the human
immune system in response to various
pathogens reducing worldwide deaths
significantly in the 20th century
as a result of water treatment so some
other
approaches to kind of mitigate disease
infectious disease
the use of vaccines and antibiotics
the death rate from infectious disease
was reduced tenfold in the 20th century
but the 21st century as we know came
around with
absolutely new challenges including
antibiotic
resistant bacteria as well as novel
pandemic viruses that we were not
prepared to
address because previously most of the
viral
diseases that vaccines were designed for
were
chronic diseases so they were infectious
diseases but they were around for a long
time
so how is bioinformatics used to study
infectious diseases
bioinformatics can be used in many
different
ways to understand these pathogens
and how they evolve so one of the
features
that is unique about the genome
is that typically the shorter the genome
the faster it changes and so the
accumulation of mutations leads to whole
groups of novel pathogens
and those could be studied using next
generation sequencing
what you see here are ways to study
evolutionary relationships to understand
the
emergence and trace the origins of
diseases
we can also look at virulence
or what causes a change in phenotype how
one virus for example can be more
virulent more infectious
we can look at protein expression and
using those proteins
design different types of molecules that
can interfere with the function
of those proteins we can use
diagnostic tools to monitor
these kinds of these kinds of viruses
and pathogens and really understand very
specifically what type of pathogens they
are
and we can also look at the population
structure and evolutionary history
by understanding the diversity of these
rapid changes
as they represent the responses to
different environmental challenges like
the host
immune response and treatments with
drugs
and vaccines
genomics and bioinformatics have
contributed immensely to our
understanding of infectious diseases
from
disease pathogenesis mechanisms of
interaction
the spread of antimicrobial resistance
to host immune responses and as a result
the emergence of genomic medicine has
substantially advanced our ability to
detect
study and treat infectious diseases
these achieve
these achievements typically come as a
result of a close collaboration between
people that understand how to apply
computer programming and databases or
computer scientists
and biologists so those people that
understand the biology of the infection
and this places bioinformatics at the
center of many current advances
in this domain so for example what you
can see here
is how we can apply different
computational tools to extract
signatures associated with the response
to
viral infection how we can trace the
lineages and study relationships between
different types of pathogens
how we can then also track the specific
mechanisms of action that are used by
viruses to for example infect the cell
and prevent the entry into the host
or how we can track the responses of the
immune system
so that we can understand better the
different types of mechanisms
and the modulation of these mechanisms
by specific
pathogens ultimately
we live today in the era of
multi-omics integration and so what we
will try to do in this program
is talk about different types of omics
data
and those types of omics data could
include
genomic data or the study of dna and rna
variation sequence variation we will
talk about
transcriptomic data which is the study
of
genes and their expression the levels
and the changes in their expression
we will talk about different types of
protein structures
how we can study the protein folded
proteins
and look at their crystallized
structures and identify
different types of active pockets and
different
unique features of those proteins and we
will talk about
the complexity of biological data
that is represented by a growing
interest in a more detailed view
from the full host to tissue specific
to cell specific so single cell data
now onyx data can be used to study
viral genomics and evolution so how do
they dynamically change over time we'll
take a look at some examples in previous
pandemics
and understand relationship between the
spread
of a disease and a particular sequence
change in the viral in the viral
community we'll talk about the
microbiome
and infection so how does the community
of microorganisms in our body
can affect the infection and the
spread of that disease we'll talk also
about
immune response and biomarkers so how
can we
detect specific changes in the host
transcriptome to understand what are the
specific
pathways that are activated and what are
some signature genes that we can trace
to understand the difference between an
acute response
and a mild response to infection
one major under way that bioinformatics
is
changing our understanding of the
microbial world
is our ability to ask basic questions
based on data and so because we have
so much data available in the public
domain
we are going to be looking at different
types of repositories
of different data sets that are
available on repositories like
ncbi the national center for
biotechnology information
and we'll look at the different ways
that people use sequencing
to study different types of
infections
[Music]
okay sorry about that um
okay does anyone have any
questions
okay does anyone have any questions
from what we discussed
so um if you have any question uh
please write it in the chat and we'll
try to make it
as interactive as possible so that we
understand
that the things that we're discussing
are clear
and there are no questions as we're
moving along so again i'll just pause
here for just a minute
make sure that there are no questions so
if you do have a question just type it
in
to the chat box
okay let me ask you how many of you
okay william is asking will be those
tools based on
free website tools um we will go over
some of the tools
just now we're going to be transitioning
to speak about next generation
sequencing so i'll introduce you to some
of the tools and you can try
them for free of course yes
okay chica is asking what are databases
or the differences between databases
and repositories excellent question so i
think
maybe a general distinction could be
made between
very different world so databases that
are very specific
for example there's a database called
ncbi virus
or there's a database called malaria gen
so these could be
general about viruses or they could be
even very specific
to a particular pathogen like malaria
and there are very generic databases
they're non-specific
and those databases include the
repository called
ncbi or era right so these are
repositories that contain
many different types of data sets that
are non-specific
so i would say that those are some
differences between publicly available
data sets
now there are also databases
that are private or controlled
with controlled access so gis aid
for example is a repository where
registration is required
and approval of your account is required
before you can actually access the data
so those are some of the databases that
we'll be going through and i'll just
list them here in the chat for you as
well
okay is it possible to analyze the viral
transcriptome
rather than or in addition to the host
with this platform
well so as we speak about next
generation sequencing
and how next generation sequencing data
looks
like you will see that the
analysis itself follows a certain logic
and that's why we call these programs
onyx logic
is once you understand the logic behind
the analysis
you should be able to take the tools
that you understand how they work
and apply them in a meaningful way
depending on what kind of data you have
so remember that transcriptomics
or the transcription or of particular
genes
means that the sequencing was done in a
specific way
and you have to map it on a particular
reference genome
with a certain level of
quality control that you could apply to
that process
so as we learn about these tools you'll
see that they are
fairly universal you can use them in
many different ways
and once you learn how to use them then
i think it's up to you
or up to the data that you have as to
whether you can apply it to a particular
type of a project or a data set
okay excellent question so alternative
splicing
can it be used in the analysis of
transcriptome of virus
so i think again one of the challenges
here as you think about viruses and how
they replicate
they replicate very differently so for
example
in the human in the host genome
there is the the specific gene sequence
with exons and introns and
there are specific regul regulatory
um assisting enzymes that are present
there to facilitate the splicing
right and so alternative splicing has
been known
to differentiate between different
cancer types for example
um or has been shown to be different at
different
stages of development and so those kinds
of alternative splicing events
are well studied in uh hosts in in model
organisms and humans and animals like
mice rats etc
in viruses i think that less of the
mechanisms that are typically used for
alternative splicing
of human genes are going to be expected
from viral genes
the virals the virus especially uh
typically
you know leverages the host machinery to
produce
its proteins and so i think it has much
less control
over how that alternative splicing is
being done and so that's why i think we
expect a lot more diversity
not only is that diversity is going to
be between virus
of the same type but different strains
but also in
different cells in in cells that are
specialized to do different things
in different tissues and different
organs and so because of that complexity
and diversity
i don't think that as much has been
studied and known about
alternative splicing in viral genes but
i think that's something that you can
definitely
try and replicate especially if you're
using things like
cell lines but i don't think that as
much has been studied
does it mean that one has to use the
host genome with respect to the virus no
i think if you want to study the viral
genes you definitely have to use the
viral genome
okay when we say data set do we mean
only the information obtained from the
genome
of an organism or does it include its
phenotype
and i think that's an excellent question
chica
so many of the databases provide us with
access to different types of data so
sometimes if the data comes from
patients
the metadata or the phenotype about the
data
could be protected and we might not have
a lot of access to that
sometimes we do have access to both the
genomic data and the phenotype
so we'll take a look at some of the
examples and we'll see
i think a difference from projects
project to project
excellent question so thank you again
for the questions i think this is really
the
intent of this session today and during
the sessions as we go through hopefully
we'll have a lot more discussion so
knowing uh what is interesting to you
and what are the questions that
pop up as you go through the session is
very informative
okay so next generation sequencing why
do we need
processing of next generation sequencing
data so the processing of next
generation sequencing data
is the process of extracting
material biological material in a
specific format
using different types of library
preparation techniques
and sequencing them to produce some sort
of
information and that is why we're going
to talk a little bit about
what are the logical steps to take this
raw sequencing information eliminate the
noise that comes with the technical
steps of data preparation
and then what type of information we're
looking for
as we quantify and analyze the data that
we have
first of all i have to mention that
there's a huge
number of data sets that are continuing
to
develop and to be available on different
types of repositories
so it seems like the amount of data has
been growing
exponentially over the past several
decades
and i think that especially in the
recent times we have seen
an amazing number of genomes that are
available
across a variety of different domains
but i think this is especially true
in the domain of virology so
specifically for
viruses and to understand that we need
to understand
how are these viruses actually sequenced
so there are many different types of
data preparation
steps that could be used to be able to
ask specific
questions of the data so data is not
just generated by
a fully automated process that process
has
a design in mind so let's
talk about three different types of
sequencing
and then we'll take a look at some of
the use cases with those types of
sequencing
one example is targeted sequencing
so a good example of targeted sequencing
is if we are looking for specific genes
that we
know are associated with drug resistance
or specific genes that encode for
proteins
that are especially critical for
viral entry for example can someone
think
of some examples of
those kinds of genes that could be
sequenced
in a targeted way and why would we do
that
so why would we sequence them in a
targeted way
okay any examples that you can think of
what do you think might be the reason or
what an example
that you might think of to target
targeted for targeted sequencing
of a particular gene
okay great so uh we have an answer from
chica gene's coding for viral spikes or
nuclear capsule right
so if we know that there is a
particular protein encoded in the gene
and we want to understand the variation
of that gene
we can focus the
the sequencing on just that one gene the
benefit of that could be that we get
higher coverage and so we can sample
in a deeper way variation of that
particular target gene
another example could be with targeted
sequencing
of malaria drug resistance genes
right so in malaria there are
thousands and thousands of genes and we
are
expecting to find some single point
mutations
that are responsible for drug resistance
if we are
sequencing a collection of pathogens
of parasites like malaria then we're
expecting to sometimes
find those mutations and sometimes not
find those mutations and so that is
where
we will benefit from a higher depth
or a greater depth of that sequencing
ephioma is saying 16s for bacterial
isolates
excellent example so when we take an
environmental sample
instead of looking at just one organism
we're looking at
many different organisms and to get some
meaningful information like their
taxonomic
assignment which taxonomy do they belong
to
it is useful to focus on the 16s
ribosomal rna gene
to understand how this conserved gene
can help us group the different types of
organisms that we have in the sample
into defined groups and william is
saying
target b protein from bacteria or
epitope prediction so if we have some
specific regions of a protein
so that we can find in the gene we can
also look for specific variations there
i think that is also one of the use
cases so
that is a targeted sequencing
now targeted sequencing is typically
for a specific sequence that we're
looking for
sometimes we're going to be calling this
amplicon sequencing so amplicon
sequencing
means that the library is designed to
amplify
using pcr primers we're amplifying a
particular type of a sequence like the
16s ribosomal rna
and then we are able to study only those
types of genes
now this is different from the whole dna
in rna sequencing and one of the reasons
is because whole rna and dna sequences
are not going to have a uniform
sequence so the longer the sequence that
we have
and the more variation in the sequence
that we have we will have
a variable coverage for that genome
and so those are some different types of
sequences so always
remember that the type of information
that we are getting
is directly related to the type of data
that we have and so when we look for
data when we are trying to find a data
set to work on
it's important to understand what are
the specific techniques
and methods that were used to present
this data to us
and that will guide us in what steps we
need to make
to analyze this data so
here we have two examples viral
outbreak methods and here we have what's
called
viral metagenomics or clinical
metagenomics
so this is an example where from the
same
biological sample you can actually
prepare
a full sequence a consensus sequence
of what we expect to find and
you can also find the specific
viral genomes that you might expect or
have levels that you might expect to
find
and that is called metagenomics ngs or
mngs now we'll talk about these in
greater detail but
let's also take a look at this site over
here here we have
an example of microorganism
identification
for example if i have a tissue or a
sample that is infected with a virus
how do i understand what virus is it
infected with
maybe i need to map it on a whole
database of potential organisms
to identify the specific type that
matches what i have in my
sample a lot of times microbiome
right so as we spoke about the different
types of environmental samples when we
are looking at
a collection of microorganisms we're
expecting a lot of diversity
and maybe we know that specific types
like
actin or bacteria or proteobacteria
right
are associated with specific phenotypes
we can also try to analyze what types of
bacteria do we have
and finally you can see right here
transcriptomic analysis
so could we find some differentially
expressed genes
that are specific to a stage of
infection
or represent the difference between
infected
and non-infected so those are some of
the use cases
some of the applications of this type of
sequencing
but also we have to remember that there
are many different
types of sequencers today so it used to
be that we had just
one type of sequencing but today we have
at least
three different platforms or four
different platforms potentially
that you can come across and so when
you're looking at data sets
that's another consideration you need to
remember that they could be produced in
different formats
and that is coming from different types
of sequences
or types of mechanisms so here we have
the pack bio sequencer you can see it's
a huge machine what's unique about pac
bio
is that they provide a fairly accurate
long sequence reads we
have the illumina different types of
voluminous sequencers
they provide typically very high
accuracy
but short sequences for the reads
and here we have iron torrents and we
also have
oxford nanopore so these are oxford
nanopore typically
lower quality but longer reads and then
iron torrent is kind of like a mix
between the two
the technology doesn't yield as much
data as
the illumina sequencers but other than
that it is comparable
so how do we analyze such
data the raw data that is coming out of
these machines
is stored in different file formats so
these
include fastq files faster files
gtf files bam files sam files etc
so to understand how we're going to go
from this raw
data that was generated using a
sequencing machine
we need to understand what is inside
these files
and what are they used for so fast queue
files
essentially contain the raw sequence
reads and this is important because
the raw sequence reads were generated
typically
on a random right they are randomly
generated
what that means is that all of
biological material that we have
has been first has been
we separated the raw genetic material
dna or rna and then that material was
shattered and so we end up with these
short sequences and the short sequences
are those reads that are going to be
stored in the sequencer
the second format is fasta the fasta
format
is typically used to store individual
reads but more often
it is used to store full genomes or
whole
sequences so for example your reference
genome
could be in a faster format or it could
be
in what's called a genbank format so the
fasta format
just contains the raw sequence and
major sections of those sequences for
example
if you have chromosomes if you have
multiple types of sequences inside the
file it could be separated
by a line with this sign in the
beginning as you can see right here
and finally we'll use the gtf file
the gta file or the gff file is
genome transfer format it is a format
where we store the beginning and the
end of annotation so for example if
we have a gene we know that this gene is
located in chromosome 11
at position 100 523
up until position 121 thousand
234 so that information
including sometimes the name of the gene
and the different
transcripts of that gene are going to be
contained
in a gtf format now the fasta file
as i mentioned could be a way to store
complete sequences the complete
sequences
for example a full genome sequence so
here you have
a fasta file of a full organism
spot of pterophobia peridot isolate sf9
scaffold 12
so a scaffold is going to be a portion
of that
genome whole genome shotgun sequence
if you have a scaffold 12 that means you
have scaffold 1
2 3 etc so you have other
here you have a complete genome so again
you'll have the id
right here in the beginning the rabies
virus and this is a complete genome
typically
for shorter genomes they're going to be
a full sequence in a fastaphile
for longer genomes they could be broken
up into parts scaffolds or
chromosomes fastq file here you have
the actual sequence of the read plus
what's called the ph red score so this
is a score
coming from the sequencer of how clear
the signal is when the sequencer is
reading
the actual chemical reaction that
produces this
image that it is capturing and
translating
into letters so this is a process
that typically is going to go downhill
from multiple uses and so every so many
runs
the machine is cleaned to improve the
quality but sometimes
we want to take a look at the quality
make sure that we
don't keep the low quality portions of
our data so that in our analysis we're
not analyzing noise right
because garbage in garbage out that is
the
destiny of bioinformatics so
how does this process work we take the
genomic information the dna or the rna
that information is shared or broken up
into
fragments and fragments could be the
length of those fragments is important
we'll talk about the length of reads and
how it applies
then those are adapter those are
connected with
adapters to to prepare the sequencing
library
and so those adapters here you can see
pair and reads
and adapters attached at the end of each
read sequence
then these are applied to flow cell
where we have
pcr bridge amplification so pcr bridge
amplification
produces enough material for the
sequencer to read
what's in the sequence and the re
reading is
uh done by synthesis with reversible
terminators so this is an example of
illumina sequences sequencers
and here you can see what those letters
look like so depending on the color
this is the result that you get and the
result comes
in a digital format so here you have an
example of what that sequence
comes out to be and this is an example
of a single
read what can you do with this
information
so for fast q files we can take the
fastq
files but because reads are
randomly generated from random pieces
that were generated from the whole
genome
the first step that we have to do is we
have to
map those reads to the reference
genome mapping them to the reference
genome
allows us to look at abundance of reads
in a particular
place like here and
that is called coverage coverage can
also be represented by a measurement of
depth
and the depth is essentially how many
reads for a given nucleotide
across the whole genome and
with faster files we can also analyze
those faster files for example we can
align perform multiple multiple
alignment sequence alignment to identify
relationships between sequences
and measure that in some kind of
way so we can measure it in terms of
distance
we can measure it in terms of
evolutionary
distance or molecular clock and assign
a time to the distance between them
so we'll talk about multiple sequence
alignment as well
importantly these sequences
are not just complete sequences
that all have very stochastic variation
they also have specific types of
sequences that we're going to be
interested in one of those basic types
of sequences
are called codons so as you remember
you have individual nucleotides in your
sequence
and that nucleotide the those
nucleotides
represent amino acids and so we can take
trinucleotide sequences and divide up
the whole
sequence that we have into amino acid
sequences why do we do that
because from the genome to the
transcriptome
to the actual proteins the sequence
changes from nucleotides to amino acids
which then fold and form functional
proteins
and so using codon mapping
we can now analyze not only single
nucleotide variations
but also mutations that are responsible
for
some kind of functional change at the
protein level
so we can perform nucleotide sequence
multiple sequence alignment and amino
acid sequence multiple sequence
alignment
and those will give you give us
different types of information
so that will give us some sense of
differences between multiple types of
genomes
at the basic nucleotide level or at the
functional level with amino acid mapping
how do we measure relationships between
sequences
one way to measure a relationship
is to look at individual sequence
changes
so positions where we observe a mutation
or a variant
another type is if we want to globally
look at similarity between sequences so
if i have
one sequence that has uh let's say
10 mutations from the reference genome
and another sequence that has 20
mutations from the reference genome
i can say well these 10 and these 20
represent some kind of a distance from
the reference
and now if i organize all of my
sequences
pairwise i can start thinking about
how do they form a
a sort of a relationship that i can
analyze
and that could be analyzed with the view
of evolution because we know that the
source of these mutations
comes from adaptation and time that's
related to time
and so we can assign some kind of an
evolutionary time
to measure the change in sequences from
an ancestor that for example we know or
we might not know
and to attach it to the present day
species or the data that we actually
have
so let's try together to perform
such analysis today and see what comes
out
so to do this what we're going to do is
we're going to go
on to a server that we're going to be
using throughout this program
and the server the account for the
server
comes with registration so that's why i
asked you all to
register today so if you could please go
with me
for those of you that have registered
please
go with me to server dot
t bio
okay i'm going to paste the link here
once you go in you should be able to log
in
using the same credentials that you used
when you signed up so when you signed up
it's important that you use your email
and you created a password so if you
have an email and a password
you should be able to sign in if you
don't have an email and a password
let me know and i'll be able to help you
and once you do sign in please put
that you've signed in in the chat box
okay do let me know in the chat once
you're signed in and
we will go through this exercise
together
okay so harris how did you
um yes if you signed in
so for example here this would be my
email address
okay if it is incorrect
um then i'll be able to uh send you
the details so um
at any point in time uh
you know okay so those of you that have
created an account today
is it should be correct um
harris um i don't know why yours
wouldn't be working
maybe if you have some additional um
so i see tori pharaoh and harris are
having trouble
signing in i will email you your details
after the session so sorry about that i
will try to
do it as soon as we're done
okay so if you are signed in
you will see here different areas of
analysis
and so today we're going to do one of
these examples
just so that everybody can kind of
navigate your way around this interface
and learn about how this works and if
you have any questions as we're going
through
please hold on to them after this i'll
pause and we'll do a little q a session
okay so what we'll do today first is we
will go right here under
phylogenetic tree and don't click on the
title itself click
right here on this drop down button
and inside this drop down button
you should see a few demo examples
so you can take any one of them i'm
going to take this demo
ebola phylogenetic analysis so
this is going to be an analysis to help
us understand relationships
between complete genomes of a virus
all right great so for those of you just
signing in again where did we go
we went under here data integration and
modeling
and to this first demo ebola
phylogenetic analysis once you
get into this section you should see
that the start button is darker and the
rest are kind of lighter
so what you can do is you can click on
the start button
and notice that in each pop-up you
typically will find
some text that explains this step
and then once you've selected that step
your next step is again going to be
darker so it's going to be highlighted
what to do next so the first thing that
we want to do is we want to perform
multiple sequence alignment so multiple
sequence alignment
is based on this idea that we have
sequences of whole genes or a whole
genome sorry
so we're looking for global alignment
between pairwise sequences
and iteratively go through all of the
possible pairs
to make sure that we can either identify
a change so a substitution
or an insertion or a deletion
and come out with a fully aligned
faster file from the faster files that
we uploaded
where we have gaps represented by dashes
and all of our sequences are exactly the
same size
so that is the first step right so
multiple sequence alignments and then
right here on top
click on ok
once you've done this remember i told
you about nucleotide sequences
and then also we have amino acid
sequences so we can do
alignment in amino acid sequences and
amino acid sequences have amino acids
have different physical chemical
properties
so these properties are useful because
we can now
look for those changes to understand
how they are represented in the
potential protein that is produced from
this
genome and then here we have select
codon position msa so
actually when we analyze the
typical mutations that occur in
different positions and codons
we know that it is not the same rate of
mutation for every
codon position and so sometimes this is
referred to third codon position or four
deposition
and you can see here that this is only
taking
that specific position in the code
now we have here different types of
phylogenetic analysis methods
these include the standard ones
including in a
r package called ape or there is a
different
package called beast which is bayesian
analysis of sequence that has
different processes that are used to
model this phylogenetic or the
evolutionary clock
essentially it's a way to model the
evolutionary clock
and to compare all of them we can just
click on all phylogeny methods
this will include all of these methods
that are listed here
and once we've generated a phylogenetic
tree with
many of these different methods we want
to compare between them
and look at the output as
as a tree space essentially that we can
also analyze for consistency
and select the best one that is most
representative
of what we think is the true biology
behind
what we have okay did anyone
create the same pipeline like me
did anyone have trouble creating a
pipeline like what you see on the screen
okay so chica if you are lost uh
let me know where are you lost
which stage are you at are you did you
start did you have trouble finding this
section in the main areas of analysis
okay at the start point so muhammad um
if you don't have the password it's the
same password
that uh you used for learn
okay so the exact same password that you
use for learn
when you sign up for learning you get a
demo account for this section as well
okay for chica just briefly i will
explain
you start create a multiple sequence
alignment of nucleotides
those nucleotides are mapped using the
genbank file they're mapped to their
amino acid sequence
then we analyze variation
at different positions inside the codon
and use that information to create a
phylogenetic tree
now we're using that multiple different
types of models
and then we're producing a single output
that is analyzed
using a tree space to identify
the most probable tree that is
representative
of what's happening in the data and so
to understand better
the results you can click right here on
download pipeline output files
and here you will have a number of
different results that you can analyze
so for example you can look at
all your your trees you can look at
one of the trees based on one of these
types of outputs
you can look at a table of all of your
positions
that compare the different positions at
the nucleotide and amino acid level if
you're interested in specific mutations
that you're looking for
or you can look also at a faster file of
all of your aligned sequences
what type of information does this
really give us
the type of information that we are
seeing
is a tree of relationships where the
x-axis
is the evolutionary time so whatever we
see
earlier in time is going to be kind of
closer to the left side
on the x-axis and we have a split
that is represented by a potential
common ancestor
and so therefore we can start grouping
this phylogenetic tree
and try to see association with the
phenotype that we have in our input data
okay so we're going to be talking a lot
about what kinds of
projects and what kinds of data sets we
can use to practice this
but here's in this example the phenotype
that we have
is location for example gabon liberia
and great britain and we have the date
1996 2014
and 2014. and so looking at this
we can see that the major difference
between
this group or this plate of the tree
is that all of them are from an earlier
time
including the reference genome and the
early time
sample that we provided as a baseline
and the later time and this later time
is also separated by location but
primarily it's separated
by time so as a result
what we can see is that this pipeline
quickly
allows us to see some major separation
into groups it allows us to understand
how sequence variation is aligned with a
molecular clock and that molecular clock
is correlated with the time that we have
but potentially we need the scale and
then it starts
it can help us start asking questions
and those questions could be much more
specific about
the specific nucleotide changes that
are different between these two groups
okay if i go to my profile i will see
this is the program that we're in by
informatics for infectious diseases
okay and here you can see some of the
sessions that are planned so we're going
to have one of these
uh synchronous one of these in-person
sessions a week
and in every one of them we're going to
be doing some kind of an
overview of a topic like next generation
sequencing today
file formats right finding different
patterns and things like that
and you will see a recommended course
so between now and our next session
the recommended course is genomics if
you just
click on this right here you will be
taken to the course
and you will see that inside there are
some practical things that you can do
so sometimes you will see this tag
learn this is theoretical material about
dna structure and variance
then we will go into working with dna
sequences in r
how do you load sequences how do you
align them
and how do you display the alignment
then we will go through an introduction
to genomics again a theoretical course
you will find a course in r you will
find a course
making a pipeline for a particular type
of a data set
performing phylogenetic analysis
comparing
sequences and then also
so as a result you will acquire skills
about the logic behind the different
data sets
you will get the idea of different types
of
pipelines that you can run for big data
so some of these data sets that we'll
use are going to be
gigabytes and gigabytes of data and so
whole pipelines are going to take
maybe tens or hundreds of gigabytes
and so obviously it's impossible to do
it on your laptop so you
have our server to practice those and
then some of the smaller curated data
sets
you will be able to work with in our
right inside of our server
so let me give you an example
so here you can see one of these
courses in r with an explanation
of the specific script
and with a practice the practice
starts with very simple assignments that
you can do
so you can for example just click run
and this these two sequences
that are loaded here as an object are
going to be
aligned and once you get the alignment
you'll also get a score
and so this kind of practice will help
you understand
how this type of analysis is done
step by step looking at both the global
objective
like doing a pipeline that we did today
or performing the analysis in r
and viewing the actual output so that
you
understand the technical part as well
okay so this is the course that is going
to
take you to our next set of topics which
are going to be related to
the specific information in this
alignment
and how to build a phylogenetic tree
that you can analyze
and study okay let me address some of
your questions so for those recommended
courses do you need to pay before access
if you have registered for the full
program so
as you saw um right here sorry
right here once you're registered for
the program
you will see what i see so you will see
your account
and your progress and you will get
access to the zoom links
and once the session is complete you
will also see the video recording right
here
and all of the associated courses that
are down here
now if you've paid for the program you
don't have to pay for anything else some
of you are lbrn
so lbrn has provided you with a full
scholarship you don't have to pay for
anything
and you've gotten access to all this for
free
after today's session so those of you
that were in today's session
and gave me your account links i will
add those accounts to the program
if you have not registered for the full
program
you can access some lessons in each one
of this
the courses for free but some of the
assignments are going to be paid so the
basic subscription is only 10
a month i think anyone can afford that
and
so you you can either go for that
asynchronous
access or if you want to also
participate in sessions like today
you have to purchase the full program
license
um okay for those of you that have a bad
internet connection
so you will get a recording the whole
session was recorded
i will share the link and the link is
going to be
right here um on uh
instead of the zoom link you're gonna
see the recording here after the session
is over okay thank you tori
again for any one of you that joined
maybe later in the session
especially for those of you that are
from lbrn and so lbrm is paying for your
account
i need your url ids just like tori
pasted right now
so that i can add you to the program
access and you will have access to all
of the resources that are required